[موسيقى]
افغانستان بلد لا تنفذ قصصه ولا ماسيه
رصدنا من قبل وفي سلسله حلقات رحلته في
البحث عن السلام وحاله في ظل حكم طالبان
ووقفنا على اوضاعه بعد عام من الانسحاب
الامريكي وكشفنا جانبا من شبكات تهريب
البشر من هذا البلد اليوم وفي الذكرى
الثانيه لانسحاب القوات الامريكيه نكشف
ابعاد معركه من نوع اخر معركه ليست ككل
المعارك التي خاضها الافغان تاريخيا
وقهروا فيها امبراطوريات كبرى معركه
تستهدف روح الانسان الافغاني وعقله وتكشف
عمق بؤسه وفقره وهو الذي يحتاج اكثر من
اربعه وعشرين مليون من ابنائه مساعده
انسانيه لمجرد البقاء على قيد الحياه قصه
عن افغانستان ومعركه الافيون حيث يعاني
ثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون من الافغان من
الادمان على المخدرات في بلد تشير تقارير
دوليه الى انه ينتج
في المئه من افيون العالم منذ اكثر من عام
فرضت حركه طالبان حذرا على زراعه وانتاج
المواد المخدره وشنت حملات على مزارع
الخشخاش ومعامل تصنيعه الا ان تقريرا
امنيا يشير الى ان محصول العام الماضي حقق
ربحا هو الاعلى منذ سنوات اما هذا العام
فتشير التقارير الدوليه الى تراجع لافت في
المساحات المزروعه بالمخدرات في قصتنا
الليله نستقصي ابعاد هذه المعضله التي
تضاف الى مئاس الافغان نقترب من شبكات
تصنيع وتجاره المخدرات وتهريبها ونرصد
مساراتها من افغانستان الى انحاء العالم
نستجب مسؤولين بارزين في حكومه طالبان عن
مدى فاعليه الحظر على زراعه المخدرات وعن
جدول محفزات المقدمه للمزارعين للاستغناء
عن زراعه الخشخاش المربحه والاتجاه الى
محاصيل كالقمح والسمسم نستكمل بقيه هذه
القصه مع شير محمد عباس تنكزعي
وزاره الخارجيه الاسبانيه ومن واشنطن
الدكتور دوجلاس اوليفنت كبير الباحثين
لقضاء الامن القومي في مؤسسه امريكا
الجديده وكبير مستشاري القياده الامريكيه
للشان الافغاني نسال ضيفينا عن تاثيرات
معركه افغانستان ضد الافيون محليا
واقليميا ودوليا عن نظره الغرب الى هذه
المعركه ومؤشرات انتصار طالبان فيها وعند
تاثرها بالمتغيرات السياسيه الدوليه
وتاثيرها في جهود حركه طالبان لنيل
الاعتراف الدولي بحكومتها لكن ما رايكم
اولا ان نشاهد القصه وبعدها الحوار
بين محاصيل الخشخاش تستعر حرب لوقف انتاج
الافيون في افغانستان
[موسيقى]
في بلغشان احدى مقاطعات افغانستان الشرقيه
كلفت وحده مكافحه المخدرات التابعه
للطالبان بمهمه جديده
طريق طويل وعرب يوصلنا الى مزارع الافيون
من منطقه الشهداء
[موسيقى]
قوات طالبان تتعامل مع محاصيل الخشخاش
بسراب
في غضون دقائق دمرت القوات المحاصيل
تنفيذا لقرار المرشد الاعلى
بعد بعد صدور مرسوم امير المؤمنين اتخذت
الخطوات اللازمه وحذرت زراعه الافيون
عمليا
وقد اعتبر القرار هؤلاء الجناه مجرمين
مجرمين وسيتم التعامل معهم وفقا لذلك
وامراض
تنتقل قوات طالبان المسلحه من مزرعه الى
اخرى لتدمير المحاصيل تقول السلطات
المحليه ان ازدهار زراعه الخشخاش في هذه
المحافظه يعود سببه لازدياد الفقر وتفاقم
الازمه الاقتصاديه
كما تعلمون كان هناك الكثير من الفقر
والبؤس وفي بعض مناطق بدخشان كان الناس
يزرعون الافيون
وقد تنامت زراعه الافيون في بعض المناطق
لكن بحمد الله تم القضاء عليها
انتشرت بين المزارعين حاله من الاحباط
والحناق لما يرونه مصدر دخلهم الوحيد انا
لا استفيد من هذه الحكومه وليست لدي
خيارات اخرى كيف ساطعم عائلتي انا رجل مسن
وفقير لا استطيع الذهاب حتى الى ايران
ماذا يمكنني ان افعل ليس هناك خيار اخر بل
انني افضل الموت
لقد استشهد ابني ولم اتلقى اي مساعده حتى
الان
لا استطيع ان احقق دخلا من زراعه محاصيل
اخرى
الاماره الاسلاميه لم تعطنا افغانيا واحدا
لزراعه محصول بديل
عليهم ان يقيموا العدل وان يطبقوا القانون
على الجميع على قدم المساواه
[موسيقى]
لدينا النيه للتعاون مع شعبنا الفقير
والعاجز لتوفير سبل عيش بديله
واذا ما كان المجتمع الدولي ينظر الى
الافيونكه مشكله فنحن ندعوه الى مد يد
العون للاماره الاسلاميه والشعب الافغاني
ليجد سبل عيش بديله ويقف على قدميه دون ان
يضطر الى اللجوء الى زراعه الافيون في
المستقبل
[موسيقى]
شهدت ولايه هالماند انخفاضا غير مسبوق في
زراعه الخشخاش لهذا العام وفقا لدراسه
اجرتها شركه ال 6 المقاطعه الجنوبيه
الغربيه كانت تعد مركز الافيون الافغاني
لعقود خلف
[موسيقى]
تم توظيف الات عمال المواسم في المزرعه
تلو الاخرى لاستخراج عصاره الافيون
الثمينه من الخشخاش
[موسيقى]
لكننا شمرنا عن سواعدنا وبحمد الله
اقتلعنا زراعه الافيون في افغانستان من
جذورها
ما هو
التاثير الاول يطال الاقتصاد الريفي
العصيه
في العام الماضي بلغ مجموع دخول المزارعين
الافغان المتاتيه من محصول الافيون مليارا
و400 مليون دولار امريكي
وبالتالي فان هذا الانخفاض الهائل يصاحبه
انخفاض هائل في دخول المزارعين الافغان
[موسيقى]
لهذا السبب اعددنا خطه احلال الخمسيه بحيث
يحل القمح وبذور السمسم والقطن والذره وما
الى ذلك من المحاصيل محل زراعه الخشخاش
على الرغم من القيود التي تفرضها طالبان
تظهر تحقيقاتنا ان حركه تهريب المخدرات لم
تشل بالكامل في افغانستان
توجهنا الى مدينه مروز الحدوديه مركز
المهربين القديم للتحقيق في شبكه تهريب
المخدرات
التقينا مهرب مخدرات وافق على التحدث
الينا شرط عدم الكشف عنهويته شكيب وهو اسم
مستعار يقول ان العمل مزدهر هنا
زياده القيود على مستخلصات الافيون تعني
ارتفاعها مش ارباحنا هنا نشتري الميث
الكريستالي مقابل 30 مليون تومان للكيلو
جرام والكيلو جرام الواحد من الهيروين ب
2,600 او الف دولار وبمجرد وصوله الى دبي
نبيعه مقابل سته الاف او سبعه الاف دولار
وفق شهاده مهربين استطاع برنامج للقصه بقي
الوصول اليهم فان عمليه تهريب المواد
الاثيونيه الافغانيه تمر ضمن شبكات
المنظمه تضم عشرات الموزعين من الذكور
والاناث لاجتياز الحدود تحدثنا الى مهرب
مخدرات ثاني يعمل مع شبكه من 40 شخصا
ينقلون ما بين صنين الى ثلاثه اطنان من
الهيروين والمثل كريستالي شهريا الى دول
في الشرق الاوسط عبد وهو اسم مستعار اشترط
اخفاء هويته
السوق مزدهر لان هناك المزيد من القيود
يبيعون المواد الخام هنا في مناطق مختلفه
انا اشتريها من باكوا واخذها الى المعمل
حيث يطبخونها ويجهزونها بعد ذلك انقل
المواد الافيونيه الى نمروز ومنها الى
الحدود الباكستانيه ومن هناك تنقل المواد
الافيونيه الى ايران
لمعرفه المزيد عن انتاج الهيروين في
افغانستان سافرنا الى منطقه نائيه جنوبيه
البلاد
تمكنا من الوصول الى معمل تقليدي للهيروين
[موسيقى]
يجهد العمال هنا في انتاج المخدر
لا يمكننا اظهار وجوههم
[موسيقى]
مهرب المخدرات يوفرون المواد الخامه
للمعمل
انتاج كميه كبيره من الهيروين من السائل
اللباني للافيون يستغرق يومين او ثلاثه
ايام من العمل الشاق
تسخن البراميل الكبيره وبداخلها الماء
المغلي ولبن الافيون وهيدروكسيد الكالسيوم
وكلوريد الامونيوم لانتاج المورفين الذي
يتحول بعد ساعه قليله الى الهيروين انتاج
كيلوغرام واحد من الهيروين يتطلب حوالي 29
كلغ من لبن الافيون
ينتج افغانستان الثمانين بالمئه من افيون
العالم وهو بلد تربطه صلات مع سوق المواد
الاثيونيه الاقليميه والعالميه كميه كبيره
من المواد الافيونيه ينقلها تجار المخدرات
برا عبر مناطق حدوديه غير رسميه
[موسيقى]
تعمل شبكات تهريب المخدرات الدوليه ضمن
ثلاثه مسارات رئيسيه طريق الشمال ويؤدي
الى اسيا الوسطى وروسيا
وطريق الجنوب المؤدي الى دول الخليج
العربي وغرب افريقيا ثم اوروبا الغربيه
اما الثالث فهو طريق البلقان الطريق
الرئيسي للمواد الاثيونيه الافغانيه الى
اكبر سوق استهلاكي لها في اوروبا الغربيه
عبر ايران وتركيا
هناك انواع مختلفه من اساليب التهريب الذي
يجري على نطاق واسع
نحن نتحدث عن كميات كبيره وشحنات كبيره
ومعظم هذه الشحنات الكبيره منشاؤها
افغانستان
[موسيقى]
الحدود الايرانيه الباكستانيه
بوابه مشتقات الافيون الافغاني الرئيسيه
الى اوروبا هنا على طول الطريق البلقان
سعينا لتقصي عمليات تهريب المخدرات في
مدينه زاهيدان وافق احد اكبر تجار
المخدرات على التحدث الينا يقول ايوب وهو
اسم المستعار ان العمليه متعدده الطبقات
وتتطلب لوجستيات ضخمه في بلدان مختلفه
لا شك ان شحنه تعبر ثلاث دول ليست مزحه
يتم تحميلها في افغانستان من كل طن من
المواد الافيونيه يصلك 100 كلغ واخر يصله
50 كلغ وثالث 100 كيلوغرام
وتصل الكميه الكامله للمندوب الذي لم نراه
او نعرف من هو هو احد المحاربين القدماء
يتصلون به ويخبرونه بانه مشترى مخدرات في
افغانستان ويطلبون منه استلامها ونقلها
نحن موظفوا هذا المندوب الذي لم يراه احد
ولا احد يعرف مكانه يمكن المهمه الينا
ونحن نقوم بتسليمها حتى لو كلفنا ذلك
حياتنا نحن نعلم ان الامر ينطوي على
مخاطره ليس امامنا خيار اخر
[موسيقى]
هنا قريبا من بلده صناعيه مهجوره مجاوره
للحدود الايرانيه الباكستانيه رصدنا
شاحنات الاستلام تحمل بالمواد الافيونيه
الافغانيه لتشق طريقها الى مدينه زاهدان
على طرق ترابيه
متجنبه نقاط التفتيش التابعه للشرطه
الطريق الوحيد المفتوح حاليا هو حدود
مشكيت
[موسيقى]
توجد غابات نستقبل داخلها الشحنه
باستخدام الحمالين نقوم بتهريبها عبر
الحواجز الحدوديه
[موسيقى]
علينا ان نسلك الطرق الترابيه والطرق
الجبليه باتجاه بام وكرمان ثم الى طهران
او حيثما كانت الوجهه
[موسيقى]
يشكل طريق البلقان ابرز ممرات للتجاره
الرئيسيه للمواد الافيونيه ضمن شبكات
دوليه تدار بتنظيم عال ويخدمها الاف
العاملين كما كشف لنا ايوب
ومن افغانستان حيث يتم تحميل المخدرات قد
تستلم الشحنه 50 يدا الى ان تصل الى
مالكها الرئيسي الذي لن اراه انا ولا انت
ولا احد يعلم ماذا يفعل او ما الذي ينوي
فعله
لدينا موظفون في كل منطقه فمثلا لديه انا
في بلوشستان
وانا انظم كل شيء
كالمسلحين والمرشدين والسيارات والجمال
والحمير هل تعتقد ان من يهرب طنا من
المخدرات سيفعل ذلك بالاهتمام ودون اي
تفكير ايا كان من يهربها فهو يعرض حياته
للخطر
هو يوظف مضحين مسلحين كي لا تضيع ثلاثه او
اربعه ملايين دولار هباء
وفقا لما كشفه لنا تجار المخدرات الطلب
على الهيروين والمثل كريستالي
والانفيتامين المنتج في افغانستان مرتفع
وقد ارتفعت اسعار المواد الاثيونيه
الافونيه بشكل كبير منذ ان فرضت طالبان
الحرب
عملنا دقيق ومدروس بعنايه نحن نتحدث عن
اربعه ملايين دولار
جميعنا نستخدم اجهزه اتصال لاسلكيه
قبل عمليه العبور يتم تخصيص سياره لنقل
المسلحين الى مناطق معينه لياخذوا مواقعهم
ياخذون مواقعهم ولا يسمح لهم بمغادرتها
حتى نصل
اذا ما استمر حظر طالبان ستشهد زراعه
الافيون تراجعا كبيرا سينعكس بشكل هائل
على الاسواق العالميه للمخدرات لا سيما
امدادات الهيروين
[موسيقى]
لكن يعتقد بعض المراقبين ان هذا قد يتاثر
بتباين مناطق تنفيذ الحظر في افغانستان
الحظر غير متساوي بينما شهدنا انخفاضا زاد
عن 80% في زراعه الافيون بين عامي 2022
وثلاثه وعشرين الا انها ما زالت قائمه في
بعض المناطق فقد تدنت في منطقه الجنوبيه
على سبيل المثال لكن في بداخشان التي تقع
في الشمال الشرقي تشير الصور الى ان
الزراعه فيها مستمره ان لم تكن قد زادت
تفاحه في الحقيقه هناك من السكان من لم
يرغب في الامتثال للحظر
كما ان بعض القاده في طالبان لم يرغبوا في
فرض حظر على سكان الريف وفي دوائرهم
الانتخابيه الريفيه
كلا هذا غير صحيح على الاطلاق
فلو لم يكن هناك تعاون وتنسيق داخل
الاماره الاسلاميه لما تمكنا من فرض الحظر
فورا
في العاصمه كابو الحياه ملايين الافوان
الطغى عليها الفقر والبؤس والياس وفق
استطلاعات في عام 2022 فان 98% من
الافغاني يعانون وقد قيمت حياتهم كسيئه
للغايه في الوقت الذي وصلت فيه حرب طالبان
على الافيون الى شوارع العديد من المدن
يعتقل الالاف من مدمن المخدرات وينقلون
الى مراكز اعاده التاهيل في بلد يقدر عدد
المدمنين فيه بثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون
وفقا لتقرير مكتب الامم المتحده المعني
بالمخدرات والجريمه في عام 2023
نشن عمليات تستهدف مصانع المخدرات في
افغانستان
كما نشن عمليات ضد تجار المخدرات
قدنا سته الاف عمليه في عام واحد ونتيجه
لذلك اعتقلنا 7000 مشتبه بتهريب المخدرات
دمرنا 600 مصنع لانتاج المخدرات
ودمرنا احد عشر الف هكتار من حقول الخشخاش
كما عالجنا 90 الفا من مدمنين المخدرات
هذا العام
هذا انجاز ضخم في عام واحد
شيئا فشيئا تحل حقول القمح الذهبيه محل
محاصيل الخشخاش في افغانستان محاصيل اقل
ربحا للمزارعين الافغان الذين يغرقون في
فقر مدقع
بعد عامين من انسحاب الولايات المتحده من
افغانستان تواصل طالبان الكفاح من اجل
الاعتراف الدولي مع تكثيف حربها على
الافيون
حرب ذات تاثيرات محليه ودوليه لا حصر لها
اذا ما استمرت
مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام وبضيفينا
الكريمين معنا من كابول الشيخ محمد عباس
ستانك زاي وكيل وزاره الخارجيه الافغانيه
ومن واشنطن الدكتور
الباحثين بقضايا الامن القومي في مؤسسه
امريكا الجديده وكبير مستشاريه القياده
الامريكيه للشان الافغاني لعلنا نبدا من
كابول ومعك السيد
بدايه ان نتساءل حقيقه رغم اعلان حكومه
طالبان حربا بلا هوادا على
المخدرات والافيون تحديدا الا انك تابعت
معنا هذا التقرير الذي كشف استمرار زراعه
الافيون استمرار تصنيعه استمرار تهريبه
واستمرار تصديره للاسف الشديد هذا السم
الى كل انحاء العالم لماذا باعتقادك
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته وعليكم
السلام
كما تعرفون
زراعه الخشخاش
ذاته تاريخ مديد يعود الى نصف قرن من
الزمن وقد زرع الخشخاش في مناطق مختلفه في
افغانستان
سيما في المناطق الشماليه
والجنوبيه الشرقيه والجنوبيه الغربيه ايضا
على مدى خمسين عاما مضت وكما تعرفون
المزارعون
المحليون جلهم
اعتمدوا على تلك
المنطق المناطق وتلك المناطق كانت محاذيه
لايران وباكستان
وعبضا عن الذره وعن القمح
وزراعتهما وزراعه المحاصيل الاخرى فكانوا
يحبذون زراعه
الخشخاشه لان المكاسب هي اكبر بلا شك
لكن هذا لا يجيب على السؤال يا سيد سالتك
انه في تحقيقنا هذا رغم الحظر المفروض من
حكومه الطالبان تستمر في الانتعاش هذه
التجاره تابعت معنا شبكات المهربين
واستمرار تدفق الافيون والمخدرات
الافغانيه الى العالم اجمع الى اين وصلت
جهود حكومتكم في هذا الاطار وما الذي يحول
دون ربما القضاء نهائيا على هذه الافه
التي كما سطرت هي ممتده منذ عقود وليست
بالجديده وحتما ان التحدي كبير
كما تعرفون
سمير المؤمنين امير الاماره الاسلاميه
افتى فتوى بحذر زراعه الخشخاشه في طول
البلاد وعرضها ومنذ ذلك الحين نحن نحاول
ان نحضر ذلك في جميع الارجاء ولكن في بعض
المناطق
النائيه البعيده ثمه الزراعه
للخشخاشة ولكن هنالك جهد للشفاف هذه
الزراعه ووفقا لتلك الفتوى فلن نسمح باي
هكتار ليزرع واي شخص ليزرع
الخشخاشة
تحول السيد اوليفانت الاداره الامريكيه
بطريقه رسميه كيف تنظر لموضوع مكافحه
المخدرات على نطاق واسع وهذه الحرب التي
تقودها طالبا مجله مثلا وصفتها بالحرب
المثيره للاعجاب رسميا ما الذي يقال حول
هذا الموضوع هل تقدر هذه الجهود وكيف يؤثر
في سير اي مفاوضات او حتى العلاقه بين
الطرفين حكومه طالبان من جهه والاداره
الامريكيه من جهه اخرى
وقدر مساء الخير لك ولمشاهدك هنالك العديد
من الاسئله في سؤالك اعتقد بشكل عام فان
الغرب مسرور بان انتاج الخشخاش في
افغانستان منخفض افغانستان تاريخيا كانت
بشكل كامل تقريبا كما كان هي المنتج الاول
للافيوم
البورما كان هنالك ينتاج لعشره بالمئه لكن
افغانستان كانت تنتج بنسبه 80 او 90% من
الافيون في العالم بالتالي القضاء على هذا
الامر هو شيء عظيم بالتاكيد هنالك تاثيران
اساسيان اولهما وكما تحدثت التقرير هو
التاثير الاقتصاديه على الشعب الافغاني في
الوقت الذي نجد فيه ان انتاج الافيون
ربما هو مصيبه لبقيه انحاء العالم لكن
لمزارعين
هو يشبه المعجزه هو يشبه هو يمكنهم من
البقاء على قيد الحياه هو محصول بامكانهم
ان ينتج مرتين او يحصد مرتين في الموسم
وقد يخسرون موسما لكن يحصلون على الموسم
الاخر وايضا المنتج وكما اظهر تقريركم هو
ربما معجون بكميات قليله بامكان ان يرسل
عبر براميل بالتالي ليس هنالك اي محصول
يشبهه وكما ذكر تقريركم ان مبيعات
الافيونه لثلاثه ملايين دولار في الطن انا
لست خبيرا وساقبل هذا الرقم لكن مثلا
هنالك ربما يباع ب 300
الف دولار للطعم بالتالي
ما يتم صنعه في
بالنسبه للافهم هو
اضعاف هذا الامر بالتاكيد هنالك معاناه
للشعب الافغاني المساعدات الانسانيه قد
انخفضت بالتالي ليس هنالك شبكه امان
لهؤلاء المزارعين الذين تم حرموا من هذه
الزراعه وليس هنالك ايضا وجود دولي يوفر
وظائف كان هنالك كما قلت ان من ترك هذه
الزراعه بامكانه ان ينضم الى القوات
الامنيه الافغانيه او ان ينضم للعمل
الوقت هذا لا يجيب على سؤالي وسالته بشكل
صريح عن تاثير كيف تنظر الاداره الامريكيه
لموضوع
يعني
محاربه حكومه طالبان لهذا الموضوع وهل
يؤثر على علاقتها بالتالي مع الحركه
نحن مسرورين ان الافيون يتم القضاء عليه
هل هي هل هو قد يقضي على البواعث القلق
الاخرى تجاه حكومه افغانستان بالتاكيد كلا
في حقيقه الامر قد لا يؤثر على تجاره
المخدرات التي كانت موجوده منذ عقود وكما
اشاره تقريركم الكثير من تجاره المخدرات
قد انتقلت الى
الهيروان الى مخدرات مصنعه مثل مثلا
الكريستال والكنتاجون ايضا والفنتولون كما
هو معروف في الصين مثلا وفي امريكا
بالتالي نعم نحن نشعر بالسرور ان الافيون
قد تم القضاء عليه تقريبا ليس له التاثير
الذي كان موجودا منذ سنين لكن عندما ننظر
الى علاقه الولايات المتحده مع حكومه
طالبان بشكل عام الامر للنيه يحرك الامور
بشكل كبير كل ذلك انتم مصرون لكن لا نفهم
تماما انتم لان رغم ذلك هناك الكثير من
اللوم لحركه طالبان فيما يخص موضوع
المخدرات لعلني اتوجه مره اخرى
في الوفد
التفاوض هنا في الدوحه مع الامريكيين وكان
موضوعا المخدرات على جدول الاعمال ما الذي
تم تناوله بهذا الخصوص ما الذي سمعتموه من
قبل الامريكيين بهذا الخصوص ربما الضمانات
التي قدمتموها الذي تم مناقشته
كما قلت في السابقه ان زراعه
الافيون الخشخاشه في افغانستان ذات تاريخ
مديد والامرته الاسلاميه الافغانيه قد
حضرت زرعه الخشخاش بالكليه واذا ما عدتم
الى عام 2000 فقد كان هنالك حظر ايضا
وقطع دابر الزراعه الى الابد في تلك
الفتره ولكن القوى الاجنبيه في عام 2001
اتت الى افغانستان
وانتهجت الزراعه مجددا ووصلت الى 80 او
تسعين بالمئه من امدادات العالم
وبسبب القوات الاجنبيه لم نستطيع ان نحضر
زراعه الخشخاش مجددا وعندما اتت الاماره
الاسلاميه لمره ثانيه وسلامه الحكم
شهدنا ان ثمه مشاكل مستعره بس بب
زراعه الخشخاشه وتهريب المخدرات وفقا لنمو
المتحده 3.5 مليون وفقا لتقديرات هناك
اربع فصل خمسه مليون من الافغانيين
المدمنين على هذه الماده على الهيروين
والمخدرات ولذا
زعمائنا قرروا
بتجديد الحظر التام على زراعه الخشخه
وهنالك فتوى كما قلت
افتى بها امير المؤمنين والسيستغرقوا
الامر وقتا ربما سنه او سنتين
لانهاء زراعه
وتحديدها الذي تتحدث عنه يبدو كبيرا لكن
هناك تشكيك من قبل المجتمع الدولي خاصه ان
هناك من يتحدث بان تجاره المخدرات هي احدى
مصادر تمويل الحركه بما يمكن الرد على هذه
الاتهامات التي تشكك حتى في نواياكم حرمه
الموضوع هناك فتوى كما ذكرت بالفعل
يكبد ربما الافغان الكثير اربعه ونصف
المليون كما ذكرت وصححت لنا الرقم الذي
ذكرناه طلب الثلاثه ونصف مليون من
المدمنين في افغانستان لكن هناك من يقول
بان طالبان تريد ان تشتري ايضا ربما
اعترافا دوليا باعلانها لهذه الحرب التي ر
غم ذلك يشككون في جديتها
ان الاماره الاسلاميه في افغانستان
كما تعرفون مصممه على هذا الحظ وبعد
انسحاب القوى الاجنبيه سيما قوى النيتو
والقوى الامريكيه المنظمته غير الحكوميه
والمنظمه الاخرى التي كانت تعمل على هذا
الجانب مكافحه المخدرات والى ما هنالك لم
توفر دعما
لمحليين الافغان ولكن بحسب قدرتنا
وبحسب قدراتنا نحن نبذل كل ما بوسعناه لكي
نحو لدون تفشي هذه
الافات سيما زراعه الزعفران وربما زراعه
محاصيل اخرى ولكن نحتاج الى دعم الاسره
الدوليه سينما الامم المتحده والمنظمات
غير الحكوميه المتحده الامريكيه والدول
الاوروبيه لكي نجتث هذه الافه من بلادنا
عد مره اخرى السيد ملفت ما ذكره السيد
فيما يخص انتعاش
تجاره وصناعه المخدرات في افغانستان خلال
الاحتلال الامريكي وقد كانت هناك اتهامات
صريحه باستفاده الامريكيين من موضوع ايضا
ولطالما في الواقع كانت المخدرات اداه
ايضا سياسيه في الصراع بين القوى الكبرى
سؤال هو الى اي مدى باعتقادك هناك مصلحه
امريكيه جديه في وقف تجاره المخدرات
القادمه من افغانستان ام انها ربما
تستخدمها هي ايضا للاضرار بدول الجوار
اعتقد الان
بعدم وجود الولايات المتحده في المنطقه او
في افغانستان فان مصالحنا قد انتهت في تلك
المنطقه عندما كان لدى الولايات المتحده
وجود كبير كان هنالك استثمار كبير في
الحكومه الافغانيه كانت مشكله انتاج
الافيونه والخشخاش كانت احدى المشاكل
المهمه الان هي مشكله لدى طلبان يجب ان
يتعامل بها عندما
يوقفوا المزارعون من انتاج الخشاش عليه من
يتعاملوا مع الفقر وقد تعاملنا مع هذا
الامر عندما كنا موجودين في افغانستان
والان هي مشكله الطلبان بالتالي بطريقه من
الطرق نحن نتعاطف معهم مع بوجود هذه
المشكله لقد عشنا مع هذه المشكله لمده
طويله ونفهمه عمقها لكن طلبان الان عليهم
ان يتعاملوا مع هذه المشكله ويتعامل معها
في سياق وجود حكومه غير قادره على تلقي
المساعدات
بالمستوى الذي كانت تتمتع به الحكومه
السابقه هي لا تستطيع تلقي المساعدات
الدوليه لكن هناك اصول مجمده تطالب بها
حكومه طالبان بالنظر لهذا الوضع الاقتصادي
الصعب رايت حتى من الافغان الذين يودون
طبعا ان لا يستثمروا في هذا السمسم لكنهم
مجبرون بالنظر لانها تجاره مربحه امام
البديل الاخر الذي يمكن ان يكون محاصيل
القمح او السمسم
هذه هي صعوبه التي يواجهها الاقتصاد في
افغانستان هو غير قادر بشكل كبير على دعمه
نفسه لانه
فقير بالموارد وايضا هو بلد حبيس جغرافيا
حيث يعاني من وضع جغرافيا صعب لقد فهمت ما
الذي يتطلبه الامر مثلا لمرور الشاحنات
عبر باكستان الى افغانستان الامر بطيء ولا
يمكن القيام به بشكل سريع عندما نتحدث عن
محاوله شحن مثلا
القمح او الزعفران او الطحين او اي ماده
زراعيه الامر ليس له فائده اقتصاديه
وطلبانيه تتعلمون هذا الامر الامر الذي
تعلمه الامريكيون والبريطانيون والنيتو من
سنوات وجودنا هناك
تبريرا طبعا للموضوع مرفوض بكل اشكاله هذه
زراعه هذا
المتاجره فيه وهو محرم كما ذكرت صدرت فتوى
في افغانستان لكن هؤلاء مطحونون اقتصاديا
وهم يتوجهون الى هذه
التجاره غير المشروعه ونتحدثون عن الافغان
وبالتالي ما البديل الذي يمكن ان تقدمه
للحكومه ويكون مغريا مجزيا يكافئ ربما هذه
التجاره او على الاقل يعني يعطي لقمه عيش
كريمه للافان
نعم كما قال ضيفكم من امريكا
افغانستان بلد فقير وخلال العقود الاربعه
الماضيه
دمرت البنيه التحتيه
عن بكره ابيها وقد واجهنا حربا طويله
امتدت على نصف قرن
وبلدنا كما تعرفون حبيسه ليس لديها منفذ
على البحر او المحيط
وجارتنا لا تتمتع باقتصاد راسخ ولكن
الاسره الدوليه التي كانت هناك
انسحبوا وقد هجرنا وتركنا ولكن هذا من
واجبنا لا نستطيع ان ناتي بعذابه جديده
للافغان بسبب زراعه الخشخاش ودينيا قربنا
اجراء ذلك
من واجبي الامم المتحده والدول الغربيه
وامريكا اخلاقيا ان يساعدوا افغانستان
والاماره الاسلاميه
والمزارعين على الارض المحليين لكي
يوفر لهم ربما توفر لهم الحبوب او حبوب
اخرى بخلاف الخشخاشه ولذلك اذا ما ساعدونا
ماليا واذا ما دعمونا سوف نستطيع بالفعل
ان نشتف هذه الافه ربما بوقت الاقل والا
والا فنحن مصممونا سوف نجتث هذه ولكن
سيستهرقون ذلك الوقت سيستغرق ذلك وقتا
اطول وبالتالي سوف ننظر في كيفيه
الايفائي بحاجات المزارعين في افغانستان
الاقتصادي يمكن ان يخفف من وطاته ايضا ما
تطالبون به الامريكيين من الافراج عن
الاصول الماليه لديهم هل من جديد بهذا
الخصوص
لغايه الان
لم نسمع شيئا ولكن نحن رفعنا طلبا للجانب
الامريكي والبنك الدولي لكي يحرروا الوصول
المجمده وايضا الحظر الذي فرض على مصرف
افغانستان واذا ما فعلوا ذلك فاننا سوف
نصل الى البنك العالمي وايضا تجارنا
يمكنهم ان يستخدموا اموالهم فيما وراء
افغانستان لكي يتاجروا بها ولكن اذا لم
يحصل ذلك فسيكون الامر صعبا بالنسبه لنا
ولذا فنحن طلبنا من الامريكيين والبلدان
الغربيه لكي يساعدونا في هذا المقام
لان هذا لن يؤثر على
الحكومه ولكن هذا يؤثر بالفعل على الافغان
انفسهم سيما المزارعين الذين يزرعون
الخشخاش تقول بانكم تريدون مساعده دوليه
دعنا نتحول عن الاقليم او دول الجوار هذه
المخدرات ما كان لها ان تخرج من افغانستان
لولا ربما هذه الحدود تسهيلات او التهريب
سمهما هل من ربما
[موسيقى]
مشاورات او مفاوضات او احاديث او حتى طلب
مساعده من دول الجوار في مكافحه هذه الافه
ان الاداره المسؤوله عن استثاثه
تهريب المخدرات تتواصلوا عن كثب مع
نظراتها في البلدان الجاره وهذه الادارات
تخططوا
لاعتراضى سبيل المهربين سيما الطريق الذي
يصل الى ايران نحن نتواصل مع الايرانيين
لكي نقطع الطريقه على الهيروين والكوكايين
اللذان يصلان الى الدول الاوروبيه لذلك
نحن نعمل معها نعم اعود الى السيد
يتحدث عن نقطه مهمه وهي في الواقع الجمعيه
يتحدث عنه ايها الافراج عن الاصول الماليه
الافغانيه الموجوده لدى الامريكيين هل
واشنطن في وارد الافراج عن هذه الاصول
باعتقادك لدعم الاقتصاد الافغاني المتراجع
والمتردي كما تابعنا وربما لمساعده حكام
البلاد في التصدي للارهاب الذي تطالبهم به
ووقف حتى الانشطه غير المشروعه وبالتالي
تحسين الوضع الانساني للشعب الافغاني ان
كان يهمها ذلك
اعتقد ان من الصعب سياسيا على اي حكومه
امريكيه ان تطلق هذه الاصول ما دام الغرب
يستمر برؤيه افغانستان على انها مكان حيث
يتم فيه حرمان النساء والفتيات من التعليم
وليس لديهم حق
تجمع وهذا ما هل الحقوق التي تعترف بها
الدول الغربيه وحيث ان التعاون ضد مكافحه
في مكافحه الارهاب لا يتم بالشكل الذي
نرغب فيه حتى الى ان يتم تحقيق هذه الامور
الى ان يتم ان يكون هنالك احترام اكبر لما
يراه الغرب على انه احترام لحقوق الانسان
سيكون من الصعب جدا رؤيه واشنطان واشنطن
عفوا ان تفكر بمساله اطلاق تلك الاصول
هو نفس حديث حديث الغرب الاداره الامريكيه
حتى انطوني بلانكن وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
قالها صراحه ان الحكومه المستقبليه
الافغانيه التي تدعم الحقوق الاساسيه
لشعبها ولا تؤوي الارهابيين هي حكومه
يمكننا العمل معها والاعتراف بها شروط
محدده كيف تتفاعل معها حكومه طالبان
[موسيقى]
نحن مررنا بحرب طويله والبلاد دمرت
بالكامل وكما تعرفون الاتحاد السوفياتي في
السابق اتى الى بلادنا واستمر في حربنا
على مدى عشر سنوات ومن ثم اشترت الحرب بين
الفرقه الافغان وبعد ذلك امريكا وانيتو
اتوا الى افغانستان وكما تعرفون الحرب
استعرض خلال عشرين سنه ولذلك كل شيء دمر
وبالتالي لا نستطيع ان نحل جميع المشاكل
بين ليله وضحاها
وكما تعرفون هذه البلاد
عانت من الدمار على 50 على مدى 50 سنه
ربما تحتاج الى 50 سنه اخرى لكي تعيد بناء
نفسها وبالتالي هذه المشاكل نواجهها
بالفعل وهذه القضايا الداخلي يحاول ان نضع
حلولا لها ونحن نناقشها ونحن بالفعل
نعلم بان العلم اساسي
وتوفير التربيه والتعليم
سواء حق طبيعي ولكن بعض الصعاب السيما من
وجهه نظري علماء الدين ولكي نضع حلول لهذه
المسائل سيستغرق الامر وقتا ولكن لم نقل
ان هناك حظر على التعليم وحظر على المدارس
الى الابد ولكن سيستغرق الامر وقتا وبعد
ذلك ان شاء الله المدارس والجامعه سوف
تفتح ابوابها اما بالنسبه للارهاب فنحن
وقعنا على اتفاق مع الجانب الامريكي في
الدوحه كما تعرفون ووفقا لذلك واعدنا
وقلنا بان الارض الافغانيه لن تستخدم
كمنصه انطلاق لتهدد امنا
الامريكيه واي بلد اخر لذا فنحن وفي في
عهودنا ولغايه الان لم يحصل اي حادثين هدد
امن امريكا وانطلق من بلادنا ولذا ولذا
نحن
وفينا
بوعودنا كما قلنا ولا يتعين على اي طرف ان
يقلق ونحن نحاول كل ما بوسعنا بقواتنا
الامنيه تبذل جهودنا مضنيه ونحن تقريبا
وضعنا اللمسات الاخيره على هذه الجهود
سيما في مكافحه تنظيم الدوله وايضا
الجماعات الاخرى السيد اوليفانت في عجاله
لو تكرمت الانسحاب الامريكي ترك كفالها
فراغا سارعت روسيا والصين لملء في
افغانستان تحديدا مشاريع ومفاوضات وغيرها
كيف ترى واشنطن موقع افغانستان في
مواجهتها مع الطرفين روسيا والصين
العلاقه ستكون اغنى بين طلبان وبين روسيا
والصين مما كانت عليهم مع الولايات
المتحده ان الحكومه الافغانيه الحاليه قد
قررت ان تتوجه نحو الشرق وليس الى الغرب
وهي تقوم باخذ اختيارات سيكون من المستحيل
لها ان تكون لها علاقه مع الغرب بالتالي
اجد ضيفك وتفسيرها بحقيقه الامر غير صادق
انا اتعاطف مع المشاكل والتي تتطلب وقتا
واموال لكن اذا ما قرر ضيفكم وقال اننا
نريد ان نعلم كل النساء والفتيات لكننا
نريد اموالا ومعلمين القيام بذلك
سيتدفق تدفق الاموال ويتدفق المعلم الامر
لا يتعلق بالمال او الوقت الامر يتعلق
بالسياسه وافغانستان قامت بوضع السياسات
سيجعل من المستحيل تقريبا ان يكون لها
علاقات قويه مع الغرب واربى بالتالي
بالتاكيد ف روسيا والصين سيصبحان شركائهما
وسيكون من المثير للاهتمام رؤيه كيف
ستتجلى الامور اريد ان اسمع وجهه نظرك
السيد حول هذه النقطه العلاقه الافغانيه
مع روسيا والصين هل هي فعلا كما وصفات
السيد اوليفانت
روسيا هي جارتنا والصين ايضا
وعلينا علاقه حسنه مع
كليهما
وسياسه الاماره الاسلاميه في افغانستان
مرتبطه بمد الجسور جسور الصداقه مع
جاراتنا سيما الصين
وروسيا وفي ذات الوقت نريد ايضا على حساب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في عجاله لو
تكرم السيد زايد
كذلك لاننا لا نريد
ان
ناتي بالصيني وروسيا الى افغانستان لكي
نطرد الامريكينا نحن نريد علاقه حسنه مع
جميع ارجاء العالم مع الدول الغربيه ومع
امريكا ودول الاوروبيه والصين وايضا روسيا
لانهما جارتين
ونحن لا نريد اي نزاعات نريده علاقات حسنه
سيما علاقات تجاريه التصدير
والاستيراد والى ما هنالك لكي نسترد
نستورد البضائع ونرسل بضائعنا نحن كصادره
نحن نريد علاقات حسنه مع جميع تلك الدول
شرقا وغربا وشمالا وجنوبا واضح اشكرك جزيل
الشكر السيد شير محمد عباس وكيل وزاره
الخارجيه الافغانيه ضيفنا من كابول كما
اشكر جزيل الشكر دكتور
الباحثين لقضاء الامن القومي في مؤسسه
امريكا الجديده كبير المستشاري القياده
الامريكيه للشان الافغاني نلقاكم باذن
الله الاثنين القادم مع بقيه لقصه جديده
توفير رعايه الله والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]